hello everyone I'm glad you all enjoyed
my video on Rashid maitre d know
yesterday I have to say after that
Bishop f6 move by a tourniquet and him
walking around and everything probably
already making dinner plans and then
returning to the board to discover Queen
Catherine f6 and realizing his nightmare
is just beginning was well quite a
moment and I will continue my series on
recognize Medina after this game now
this game was suggested to me by user on
a previous video of mine he said please
do the groom felt vs alaka'i in 1923 and
I said well ok if it's the game I think
you're referring to them no problem and
he said it was the famous Bishop check
and yeah I knew this was the game he was
talking about so I decided to do this
game for today's video and after this
game I will return to the image Mateen
of series so this game was played by
Ernst groom Falls versus Alexander
Alekhine and a couple of words about the
players so grünfeld was very poor from
very young age and he was his like in
his early childhood and well if he
didn't discover check he would probably
have a very dull life but picking up
chess he became well what he is in
today's history and well probably
Grunfeld was in his prime from somewhere
from 1914 to 1918 but this was a period
of the world war 1 and so he couldn't
play any very strong matches so during
this time well he took up theory and
openings and somewhere around 1920 C
became known as quite the open opening
expert so in 1921 he won a couple of
very strong tournaments and in 1922 well
he introduced what is today known as the
groennfell defense and he had a lot of
success with it now Alexander Alekhine
and Ernst Grunfeld played 10 games
throughout their lives together and out
of these 10 games
Alexander Alekhine won four games he
lost one and five games were drawn but
it's interesting that the one game
Alexander Alekhine lost was
in the Broomfield defense and also I
think it's interesting that well even
though Greenfield was such an opening
expert and I'm sure you all know of
elexander Ella kind to be a deadly
executioner and a composer of beautiful
positions but he was also somewhat of a
scholar and also somewhat of a of an
opening expert so not even roomfuls with
all his knowledge could achieve an edge
in the opening so let's see this game
groom for this white and Ella Khan is
black so we have d4 Knight to f6 c4 e6
Knight to c3 d5 Bishop to g5 Bishop to
e7 I will not comment on any moves in
the opening sense like I said this is
all by the book and the both of these
players are extreme opening experts so
we have Knight to f3 Knight B to d7 III
Alec on castles rope to c1 c6 Queen to
c2 we have a six a three h6 Bishop to h4
rook to e8 Bishop to d3 D captures on c4
fish catchers on c4 b5 Bishop to c5 rook
a to D 1 D captors and d4 Knight gets
474 and now Queen to b6 developing the
Queen and also again her out of the out
of the way from that row can be won and
this is quite a standard position in
this opening does play disposition with
black and with white we have Bishop the
b1 by Grunfeld and this Bishop to be one
move is a very nice move as you see he
is eyeing this h7 square so by doing
this Bishop to be one movie is actually
paralyzing both of these Knights this
nice and d7 cannot move because if this
Knight moves anywhere
then simply Bishop captures on f6 is
deadly because nothing is defending h7
anymore so after Bishop to be won
none of these Knights can move in this
is quite paralyzing so alkyne plays
Bishop to b7 putting his Bishop on this
nice diagonal
group of castles and now elegant plays
rook a to C a2 just putting that rook on
a nice open file
and harassing White Queen a bit so
roomful place win32 getting the Queen
out of the way we have Knight to e5 and
now green fold captures the knight on f6
Bishop captures on f6 and now Queen to
c2 since there's no defender of the h7
square room fold the tries this again so
Alexander ellika has to play g6 and now
he moves the point out of the way 22 so
we have nice to see 4 and Bishop the e4
and this Bishop to e4 is a nice move
because Grunfeld is actually threatening
to play Queen to f3 next move and attack
the bishop on B 7 twice and also attack
the bishop on f6 and here alkyne would
have to capture the bishop on d4 and
roomful would capture this strong Bishop
on f6 so elegant moves his Bishop back
to g7 to prevent this so we have Bishop
captures n b7 Queen captures mv7 and now
rook a to C 1 and here Alexander
Alekhine
finds a very nice idea he pushes 'if
I've kicking this act away so Knight to
b3 and now plays the somewhat of a
counterintuitive idea he pushes e4 and
although this seems to be blocking this
Queens attack on g2 this isn't very
important anymore
more important is awaking this dragon on
g7 and one one more thing it does is it
creates a very nice outpost on d3 for
this knight on d4 so we have nice to d4
rook to e8 rook at the d1 opposing
tonight at the rockin d8 and now
alicante plays nice to e5 preparing to
go for dead be 3 square so roomfuls
plays in 92 a2 so he has a place for
this rook when night comes on d3 so we
have 9 to d3 attacking the rook and c1
and now Granville captures on c8 we have
Queen captures on c8 and now f3 groom
field would love to exchange it this
pawn and the kick this Knight from g3
somehow but of course Ella Khan does not
allow that
Ella kind plays rook captures on d4
and this is a very interesting variation
let's see what happens if the rock is
captured and rook captures and e4 is
objectively the best to move and it is
the winning move but let's just see what
happens if the rook is captured so if I
capture than d4 you would get Bishop
captures on d4 would check and the King
has to go to f1 if he goes to h1 then 9
2 f2 will be deadly
we have nice to f4 attacking the Queen
and now White has the player up to c1 to
attack black screen so we have Queen
captures on c1 with Czech Knight
captures on c1 and now Knight captures I
need to and the White has to recapture
because he's down a piece so Knight
captures an e2 and now Bishop captures
on b2 and White has to recapture here so
f captures on e4 and if you look at this
position well for black disappoint up
but this point is also going down really
fast on a 3 so we have bonds on both
sides of the board alekan has a bishop
and he will be two pawns up and this is
completely winning for blacks and of
course a group of saudis so he decided
not to capture the rook after Alec I
played rook captures on d4 but he played
F captures on e4 and now he's attacking
the knight and d3 and also the rook but
by doing this he allows elephant to do
what L kind
what Ella kind does best and that is
pure execution so Alec ein plays Knight
to f4 so let's see what this move does
this move well he gets his night away so
he cannot be captured and forces the
groom foot to capture this night with
the e pawn because he's he's attacking
his Queen now and he's also attacking
the rook and e1 so the knight has to be
captured so wrongful plays he captures
on f4 and now I think definitely the
best move of the game and this is pure
execution elegant plays Quinta c4 and
what he did with this move he is still
threatening to capture the rock and e1
but he's also threatening to capture the
Queen and need to and if the Queen moves
to protect the rook or
thing dinella kind simply captures the
knight on a - and well this practically
forces White's to play Queen captures on
c4
but now Ella Cain has this roof captures
and the one with check so if the King
moves to f2 then Ella can was sleeping
simply capture the Queen and he will be
a whole rook up so after after this rook
to d1 check there's no other move for
groom fall to play between to f1 and
this is the move the user was referring
to when he says do the one with the
famous Bishop check here we go Bishop to
d4 check and in this position
Broomfield resigned because well only
move the Queen cannot block since the
rope is spinning her from d1 so the only
movies King - h1 and this will result in
rook captures and f1 woods checkmate so
a very nice game a very famous game and
I think it's it's important to say that
well with with all his great knowledge
of the openings and theory braunfels
could not achieve an edge in the
openings against Alexander Alekhine so a
very nice game I hope you enjoyed it and
like I said I will continue my series on
maturity know after this game maybe
maybe I will be able to post a game by
net ratinho even today I will I will see
and as usual you can check to my
previous videos here and for those of
you who are interested in my live
streams I will make a tournament for
subscribers
tomorrow tomorrow morning at 9:00 a.m.
on Friday and I will put the link when
the tournament will start in the
description of this video so that's it I
hope you enjoyed this game and I will
see you soon